STEVE: NEW YORK STATE GOVERNOR
ANDREW CUOMO TRIED CONVINCE
YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET VACCINATED
BY SAYING THIS.
>> THERE IS AN ATTITUDE THAT
THEY WILL BE FINE, WHY SHOULD
THEY TAKE THE VACCINE?
MAYBE YOU GO HOME AND KISS YOUR
GRANDMOTHER AND WIND UP KILLING
YOUR GRANDMOTHER.
I DID NOTHING WRONG.
AND, PERIOD, AND I’M NOT
RESIGNING.
BRIAN: WOW, REMEMBER THAT?
HAVING TO LISTEN TO THAT EVERY
DAY?
DID ANYONE IN THE MEDIA REPORT
ON THOSE COMMENTS FROM THE SAME
MAN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NURSING
HOME SCANDAL THAT COST SO MANY
SENIORS THEIR LIVES?
HOW ABOUT 13 TO 15,000 ELDERLY
LIVES?
NOBODY DID.
AINSLEY: HERE TO REACT IS FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND MEDIA
OPINION COLUMNIST FOR THE HILL
JOE CONCHA.
HEY, JOE.
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYBODY.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION KNOWING HE
IS IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION AND THIS SCANDAL
AND YET HE IS SAYING THAT ABOUT
KISSING YOUR GRANDMOTHER?
>> YEAH, HUD PA IS WHAT COMES TO
MIND HOW MANY GRAND PARENTS DID
ANDREW CUOMO KILL WHEN HE
DECIDED TO PUT COVID POSITIVE
PATIENTS BACK INTO NURSING
HOMES.
EVEN A 10-YEAR-OLD KNOWS YOU
DON’T DO THAT IN THAT SITUATION
WHEN HE HAD THE USS QUHORST AND
JAVITS CENTER THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION GIVEN HIM AND
DECIDED TO GO AHEAD WITH THE
NURSING HOMES AND WORSE IS THE
COVER-UP THAT HIS OWN AIDS HAVE
ADMITTED WAS DONE IN ORDER TO
GET A BOOK DEAL ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
A BOOK DEAL THAT MADE ANDREW
CUOMO VERY RICH.
MOST OF THE MEDIA, AINSLEY, HAS
MOVED ON.
THEY ARE QUITE APATHETIC, IT
REMINDS ME OF GOVERNOR RALPH
NORTHAM IN WEST VIRGINIA EVERYBO
THOUGHT HE WAS TOAST.
NEWS CYCLE TOUT SEA AND NOTHING
TO SEE HERE ANYMORE.
THE FACT IT WAS COVERED 0.0
SECOND BY ALL THOSE NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS SHOWS THEY ARE
SERVING AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BELIEVE ME, IF THIS WAS RON TEE
SANTS THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA
THAT HAPPENS TO HAVE AN R NEXT
TO HIS NAME YOU WOULD BE HEARING
ABOUT THIS NONSTOP.
HERE HAVE YOU ANDREW CUOMO STILL
BLAMING DONALD TRUMP FOR HIS
PROBLEMS WHICH IS QUITE IRONIC
WHEN YOU CONSIDER IT’S THE
DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT’S RUNNING TWO OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE NURSING
HOME SCANDAL RIGHT NOW.
BUT HERE’S THE BAD NEWS IF YOU
ARE ROOTING AGAINST ANDREW
CUOMO.
SIENA POLL SHOWS 57% OF NEW YORK
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE HE IS DOING A
GOOD JOB.
THAT TELLS HIM THAT HE COULD RUN
AGAIN FOR RE-ELECTION AND HE
COULD WIN POSSIBLY A FOURTH TERM
BUT LEE ZELDIN IS GOING TO POSE
A VERY FORMIDABLE CHALLENGE
THAT’S FOR SURE.
RIGHT NOW HE SHOULD BE IN MUCH
WORSE SHAPE BUT THE MEDIA
PROTECTING HIM HAS BUOYED HIS
NUMBERS A BIT AND THAT’S
PATHETIC, GUYS.
STEVE: NOT JUST MEDIA BUT SOCIAL
MEDIA AS WELL.
WE WILL FIND OUT LATER TODAY
WHETHER DONALD TRUMP IS ALLOWED
BACK ON FACEBOOK.
THAT’S GOING TO COME OUT LATER
ON TODAY.
BUT, YESTERDAY, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT LAUNCHED A NEW
WEBSITE.
IT’S FROM THE DESK OF DONALD
TRUMP AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT HE IS
ABLE TO DO IS HE IS ABLE TO PUT
OUT STATEMENTS VIDEO COMMENTS,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT UNLIKE SOCIAL MEDIA, THERE
WON’T BE A LOT OF INTERACTION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
WAY, HOW THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS
KIND OF GOING AROUND THE SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES TO GET THE WORD
OUT?
>> IT’S A START.
RIGHT?
IT’S SOUND UP BLOG YOU COULD
CALL IT, I GUESS.
IT’S A WAY TO GET HIS MESSAGE
OUT TO YOUR POINT AND OBVIOUSLY
GO THROUGH THE -- OR GO AROUND,
ANYWAY, THE FILTER OF THE MEDIA.
BUT I THINK HE HAS TO BRING IT
UP TO ANOTHER LEVEL QUITE
FRANKLY, GUYS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
PRESIDENT LAUNCH PROBABLY A
PODCAST WHICH WOULD BE A VERY
GOOD WAY FOR HIM TO TALK ABOUT
ITEMS OF THE DAY, PARTICULARLY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
THEIR MOVES IN TERMS OF
UNRAVELING EVERYTHING THAT HE
HAD ACCOMPLISHED DURING HIS FOUR
YEARS.
HEARING THE VOICE OF THE
PRESIDENT WOULD BE BETTER.
I KNOW THERE IS A VIDEO ELEMENT
TO THIS.
I THINK THE PODCAST WOULD SERVE
THE PRESIDENT WELL HERE THAT
FACEBOOK ANNOUNCEMENT THIS
MORNING -- GO AHEAD, BRIAN.
BRIAN: I WAS GOING TO SAY WITH
THAT PODCAST WOULD APPLE PUT IT
UP WOULD SPOTIFY BE ABLE TO
CARRY IT AND WOULD iTUNES BE
ABLE TO CARRY IT.
>> MOST LIKELY NO.
THAT’S WHAT WE’RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM FACEBOOK I WOULD IMAGINE
THIS MORNING THAT THE BAN WILL
CONTINUE BECAUSE FACEBOOK, JUST
LIKE MANY IN THE MEDIA SERVE AT
THE PLEASURE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
AND, LOOK, WHEN YOU SAY WELL,
HOW COULD FACEBOOK GET AWAY WITH
THIS?
WELL THEY ARE A PRIVATE BUSINESS
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
THEIR BOTTOM LINE IS VERY GOOD.
FACEBOOK’S STOCK IS UP 100
POINTS IF YOU LOOK AT MAY 5TH,
2020 UNTIL NOW, THAT’S MORE THAN
50% JUMP.
BEFORE ANYBODY SAYS WELL THEY
HAVE GOT TO BE BROKEN UP.
WHO IS GOING TO DO THAT EXACTLY?
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRATIC HOUSE, A
DEMOCRATIC SENATE AND BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS
GREATFULLY INDEBTED TO FACEBOOK
FOR ALL THE HELP THEY GAVE THEM
DURING THE CAMPAIGN AS DID
TWITTER SO WE ARE NOT GOING TO
SEE TOO MUCH ACTION AS FAR AS
BREAKING UP THESE COMPANIES OR
SECTION 230 BEING AT LEAST
AMENDED OR REMOVED AT THIS POINT